à vous ma très chère julie qu avez-vous
choisi de faire de la prochaine fête de
l'île aux enfants
bien j'hésite encore entre la danse le
chant la poésie ou le trapèze
décidemment je trouverais personne pour
s'occuper du vestiaire je crois que je
vais me décider pour la danse d'ailleurs
bon braves alors j'inscris julie dans ce
jeu c'est ce que les vous avez mille
campagne
pour sur moi je pense qu'un petit
morceau de danse classique comme ceux ci
voient loin possible jérémy l'impossible
à bompas moiselle julie le fait déjà ah
bon dans ce cas un petit air d'opéra non
non non non non non non non non non non
très bien ou
très bien tout à fait ce qu'il nous faut
merci je ne
à khadim hier que comptes tu nous faire
pour la fin de leurs enfants moi ce sera
une surprise
enfin kazim est important que je le
sache si vous même le président est
l'organisateur bon je veux bien voulu
dire mais aa boussole oui d'accord je
vais m'habiller en cuisiniers avec un
grand chapeau et j'aurais cyprès en
fermant les yeux les meilleures recettes
que je connais prenez un gros saucisson
viendra trempé l'eau dans la contribuer
à maintenir en étonnant casimir très
bien pas maintenant mais j'ai un récital
de poésie culinaire très bien très bien
à la france a alors les pas encore fait
part de vos projets eh bien écoutez
c'est tout simple je vais vous dire des
poëles que sont les amis devenus maîtres
jaser j'assume fred et jamy et c'est
déjà fait casimir c'est pas grave je
vous chantera une chanson voilà la
chanson dont la naissance était fatale
cette échappée et c'est déjà pris par le
facteur et 1014 c'est pas grave
je danserai voilà c'est ça je danse dans
la danse la date la danse aussi ses prix
par magie et le 6/9 vous voyez bien
ennuyé alors écoutez si tout est pris
mais moi je sais pas quoi inventer bon
ben je peux vous inscrire au vestiaire
très bien je n'ai pas question ni dans
le vestiaire mais je tiens à faire
partie du spectacle d'un artiste
pourquoi derrière il ya encore un numéro
effectivement qu'il n'ait pas pris celui
de d'illusionniste de presse des gîtes
acteurs de 2,2 de magicien quoi magicien
c'est que j'y connais rien lâché sur
aucun tour pro voyons france soir s'en
vont comme vous êtes et étonnant que
vous ne trouviez pas quelques tours
patil a inventé comme par exemple je ne
sais pas moi ou l'art qui apparaît une
car
je veux bien essayé mais je vais vous
prendriez vous braves alors je peux
marquer françois dans son numéro
d'illusionniste s'ils ont un effet
qu'après ça sonne bien alors bientôt
[Musique]
tout seul j'y arriverai jeune et
je vais demander à leonardo mais était
un
nom françois les rangs commencent enfin
c'est pourtant facile tout est indiqué
là dans mon livre un tu plies
soigneusement les foules ardente amant
non françois envoyons ils font des
manchons sinon tu ne pourras jamais
faire apparaître les foulards dans ta
main
moi je tombe d'accord
françois timbre est
resté chez moi ça me fait ça me fait
rien tu rappes être à tous un tour chez
toi maintenant que tu as compris alors
de façon à notre tour voilà le sens
l'isaf a lésé je le connais bien s'il a
déjà refait alors là et bien triomphe
l'un
je prends l oeuf dans la main droite sa
main droite je referme moi je vais le
faire disparaître
[Applaudissements]
regarde
mais disparu
et où se trouve-t-il il sait trop où
il se trouve
ici et dian dans ma main je suis forgé
réussi à fuir la
france moi je ne voudrais pas te vexer
mais c'est moi qui lui réussit surtout
avec un témoin cette année
merci regarde bien je vais grand baie
cette
voie
est maintenant
où se trouve-t-il est un accord il se
trouve
qu'ils se trouvent
et s'engage en tapant ch
derrière
se trouve dans la poche
oui ça alors
c'est parfait tu as tout compris j'ai
tout compris c'est pas difficile parce
que tu
j'ai rien compris
bon allez françois ne nous énervons pas
cette plaie et reprenons à 0 tu prends
un an je prend 1,9 -
julie tu n'as pas vu françois rannou je
ne sais pas ce qu'il peut bien faire ce
n'est pas normal il se passe quelque
chose de pas ordinaire des malades
d'après léonard il est en train de
préparer un numéro de magie formidable
pour la rue de lille à raleigh la tient
nous voilà qu'arrive là bas où il est
tout pâle avec une valise à julie
bonjour casimir casimir c'est toi pour
je voulais voir tu perds les eaux je
t'en prie bonsoir quand il ya un secret
je ne suis jamais de la confidence je
t'écoute françois bon voilà casimir
tu sais que pour la fête de l'île aux
enfants je prépare le numéro de magie et
en armes en a parlé or pour certains
numéros je ne peux pas tout faire seul
là il me faudrait quelqu'un de mal à
quelqu'un de soigner pour me passer les
objets les uns après les autres enfin
pour me servir de partenaire moi je vois
à la description que tu dois penser à
moi bravo
c'est très simple casimir voilà dans
cette ligue
tous mes objets sont rangé soigneusement
alors il te suffira congelés demanderai
de me passer les objets les uns après
les autres à cécile dubois ils sont tous
numérotés 1 2 3 4 et c'est bon mais mais
tout ça me paraît très facile c'est pas
si facile que ça casimir car si te
trouves une seule fois en mélangeant les
numéros
et bien je rate ou tu peux avoir
absolument confiance en soi je vais
faire mes valises et la ranger
soigneusement dans le kiosque de julie
merci casimir et je vais m'habiller pour
la paix à tout à l'heure la foire à tout
à l'heure
voyons voilà
au sud ajouté zut qu'est-ce que je suis
maladroit ah bon il faut absolument que
je range tout ça avant le retour de
françois
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs je
l'honneur de vous présenter
l'exceptionnelle unique le seul
véritable jeu nommé françois launay
médias
[Applaudissements]
chaque mot casimir
jubault un foulard un foulard
je prends tu attends tu en voilà je
prends un foulard jeu j'en fais une
petite boule et
je fais apparaître
hoeness
[Musique]
je fais disparaître cet escargot
maintenant je vais faire apparaître une
colle au bout je tape dans les mains
et jaurès apparaître la colombe
et voilà la colle
ne sais pas
je prends une carte attaque car ça vient
quasiment tout cas merci je pense aux
jeunes car avant je prends une carte
je tape dessus et je vais la faire
disparaître
et la caf tout n'y est plus
et listant cas
on
se trompait pas partir de mélanges de
noix angers sages avaient arrangé ça
mesdames et messieurs pour présenter moi
monsieur dix noix bah oui oui oui
voici casimir
non mieux mieux que ça mieux que ça vaut
mieux que ça si c'est prévu ce bon alors
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs voici
l'assistant de francs soit le seul
l'unique la comparables les championnats
casini
mais merci messieurs
mesdames et messieurs la première partie
que vous venez de voir lesquels
volontairement raté
jeudi mais tais toi c'est un gag ça
valait savary voici maintenant la
deuxième partie
ici françois
regardez le bien
attention
3 mais voilà
c'est rien c'est tout cela c'est rien
kazemi